hi this is fresh to occur last week I
presented the marble color puzzle and
this week I'll go over the solution we
started out with three blue marbles and
three red marbles which we placed under
bowls under one of the bowls I placed
two blue marbles under another Bowl I
placed two red marbles and under the
final bowl
I placed the remaining one red and one
blue marble at this point we can label
the marbles
there's blue one blue to red one red two
and blue three red three if I select one
of these bowls at random there's a
two-thirds chance that both marbles will
be the same color either blue or red so
that's one way to see the answer is
two-thirds is that under two-thirds of
the bowls both marbles have the same
color but let's go through another
explanation let's imagine we randomized
the bowls and I'm going to pick one of
the bowls at random and one of the
marbles under the bowls at random as
well so I picked out a red marble at
random so we know this bowl cannot be
the two blue marbles so what we have is
that this bowl is either red one and red
two or blue three and red three notice
there are three ways to pick red marbles
we can either pick red one the mark and
the other marble will be red too we can
pick red to the other marble will be red
one or we could pick red three and the
other marble will leave blue three so
there's actually a two-thirds chance
that the other marble is red and that's
why the answer is 2/3 I hope you liked
this video please subscribe to my
channel you can get my books listed on
my website catch me on my blog mind your
decisions on Twitter at presh tell
walker and you can support me on patreon